In this video we will talk about another way
for imaging data, called a histogram,
which is a modern word for a less modern thing.
I think it's probably right to say that the histogram
is the most used way of presenting data.
Let me show you how to make a histogram for some data
and I think you will understand the essence very easily.
I have some data here and
I want to present them with a histogram.
We'll see how often each of these numbers is.
And to clarify this, let me write the numbers below
and categorize them in the appropriate categories.
I have here 1.
I have 1.
I have 4, I want to leave room for 2, 3
and put 4 here.
I have 2.
I have 1.
Let me put this 1 on top, just above the other 1.
I have 0 - let me put 0 left of 1.
I want to put them in order.
I have 2, another 2.
Let me put it above the first 2.
I have one more.
Let me place it above the other 2 units.
I have another 0.
I'll put it there.
I have another one.
One more 1.
Then I have another 2.
Another 1!
I have two more zeros.
0, 0.
I have two more pairs.
Two 2.
I have 3.
I have two more units.
Two units.
Another 3.
Then I have 6.
No 5, then I have 6.
The place there was not necessary.
But here I simply copied these numbers
and I actually categorized them.
Now I want to calculate how much of each of these numbers we have.
Let me start at the bottom.
I want to look at the frequency of each of these numbers.
The frequency of each of these numbers.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4 zeros.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 units.
I have 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 pairs.
I have 1, 2 threes.
I have one 4 and one 6.
So we can write it this way.
We can write the number
and then the frequency.
Frequency.
I have the numbers 0, 1, 2, 3, 4,
we can also put 5 there,
although 5 has a frequency of 0.
We have 6.
0 was shown 4 times in this data table.
1 has been shown 7 times in this data table.
2 was shown 5 times in this data table,
3 was shown 2 times,
4 showed 1 time, 5 did not show,
and 6 was shown 1 time.
I simply counted this dataset.
But you may ask yourself how many times we see 0.
I see it 1, 2, 3, 4 times.
How many times do I see 1?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 times.
That we mean by "frequency".
The histogram is actually just a graph, a kind of column diagram,
showing the frequency of each of these numbers.
It will look very similar to
this initial thing I drew.
Let's draw some axes here.
Here the different fields are the numbers.
And that's because we're dealing with very clean whole numbers,
which are repeated.
If we work with data where the numbers do not repeat,
people will often put the numbers in columns or categories.
But here they fit in nice little fields.
We have the numbers 0, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 6.
These are the numbers for the moment.
And then on the vertical axis
we will set the frequency.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7.
This is 7, 6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
0 is displayed 4 times.
We'll make a small column diagram here.
I'll do it just like that.
0 is displayed 4 times.
That's the information right there.
1 is displayed 7 times.
I'll make a small column chart.
Exactly.
I want to make it a bit clearer than that -
1 is displayed 7 times.
7 times.
2 - I will do it in another color - 2 is displayed 5 times.
2 is displayed 5 times
Make a column chart, go up to 5.
2 is displayed 5 times.
3 is displayed twice.
We have two 3.
4 is shown here once.
5 is not displayed at all.
Here we will not have any height.
Finally, 6 is shown 1 time.
I will make 6 appear 1 time.
What I did here is a histogram.
Here is a histogram.
A very modern word, but I think you will agree,
that the idea is quite simple.
We clarify the frequency of each of these numbers,
then we present it on the chart,
and we get a histogram.